also jeder einzelne größe die es von
blöcken gibt jede einzelne anordnung die
schienen das feuer in allen möglichen
varianten in denen es angezeigt wird
jeden einzelnen blog den es in minecraft
gibt habt ihr diese einzelnen welt hier
drin
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft facts heute am freitag das ist
ein bisschen komisch das zu sagen weil
ihr eigentlich sonst mal am dienstag
kommen ich bin nach und als er die kuppe
ich auch schon ein bisschen komisch an
naja ich hab mir halt einfach gedacht
ich hab seiner letzten folge schon
gesagt wenn ihr 10.000 likes knackt dann
weiß ich dass mindestens noch 10.000
leute diese folge auch am freitag
schauen wird nun macht die serie extrem
viel spaß und habs geknackt das hat mir
sind mittlerweile schon über 20.000
likes auf der folge also daumen hoch an
der stelle an euch an
ich will ja ich wollte euch jetzt der
wille jeanette habe ich bei twitter
gepostet weil ich weiss nicht weil ich
ein williger skin habe und das ist ganz
cool und gefällt mir ein bisschen besser
als ananas und ihr seid jetzt meine
villiger paradies und ich muss noch eine
richtige begrüßung dann überlegen damit
das ganze mit wir eine gruppe sind die
wir halt sagen können und allerdings was
mir leute gesagt haben die es gibt immer
noch leute die tour komplett contra
dieses geheimnisvolle geräusche sind und
deswegen hat mir die glatthaar armani
ich hoffe ich spreche dann richtig
ausgeschrieben wie wärs denn wenn du
einfach zum beispiel dienstags das
geräusch macht und freitags nicht dann
hätten doch irgendwie alle was von oder
also die die kein geräusch wollen
schauen halt nur freitags oder so
natürlich nur wenn du das dann freitags
auch machst egal ist auf jeden fall nun
idee also danke an klappt ja ich weiß
nicht genau wie man den namen ausspricht
oder ob es ein fan fiction namen
fanfiction ist auch vollkommen egal
jedenfalls finde ich die idee richtig
geil das heißt heute in dieser folge
wird kein geheimnisvolles geräusch
drankommen
also an alle die sonst warum gerettet
haben öl lass das weg mit dem
geheimnisvollen geräusch die gucken
jetzt quasi mal freitag soll da kommt
kein geheimnisvolles geräusch und das
geräusch kommt dann immer dienstags an
müssen die halt die folge nicht
anschauen aber dann verpassen sie halt
auch ein perfekt aber das halt einfach
so denke ich echt ne ganz coole idee und
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
dem
effekt und zwar hat mir jonas
geschrieben kontrast ich habe gerade die
1.8 ausprobiert und gleich mal dass mit
der spinne linksklick daraufhin gamer
drei ausprobiert als wir machen das
erstmal gamer 3 ich bin in der spinne
hatten wir ja schon in den letzten
beiden folgen dieser effekt allerdings
dann bin ich ins menü gegangen und habe
eine neue welt erstellt und tada das
machen wir doch jetzt einfach mal wir
gehen jetzt mal hin
wie man hört die welt so genannte sowie
craig jetzt einfach mal eine neue welt
in den creative modus gehen da rein und
ich bin in der spinne drin allerdings
ihr seht schon das bin ich wenn ich in
der 54
und dann bin ich auch wieder raus aber
ich kann diese spinne halt steuern wenn
ich euch dass beispielsweise jetzt hier
noch mal ganz kurz ich bin hier schon
gamer
wenn ich jetzt hier beispielsweise eine
spinne nehme dass es quasi die ablauf
ist durch eine spinne geht in den games
3 könnte links liegt drauf machen dann
seid ihr in der spinne so lange weg
machen mal uns wieder eine neue welt
machen und sicher in den creative mut
und jetzt sehen wir jeden moment den
world billing daran dass wir in dieser
spinne zweimal auch drin sind allerdings
sehen wir unsere hand und wir können
diese spinne steuern das heißt wir
können jetzt hier quasi rumlaufen mit
der ansicht einer spinne das ganze
ruckelt dann noch ein bisschen weil das
halt nicht so die normale sicht ist das
gleiche sollte eigentlich auch beim trip
ort beim ändern passieren beim krieg hat
man ja diese grüne sich dann beim ändern
nennen hätten könnte ja mal selbst
ausprobieren und sobald der eine fünf
drücke bin ich halt wieder in der
normalen ansicht und dann läuft das
ganze auch schon viel flüssiger und ich
würde sagen ich bedanke mich auf jeden
fall bei dir jonas für diesen sehr cool
effect dass man quasi auch die spinne
steuern kann bis man fünf drückt und das
perfekt so freunde kommen wir zur nummer
zwei und zwar kennt dir wahrscheinlich
diesen command gilt dann euren ingame
nahmen beim mops bonner dann bekommt ihr
einen mops pollern minecraft und wenn
man die ganz normal hin setzt dann sehen
wir da drin ist ein schwein also das ist
kein ganz normales bonner sondern das
ist einfach so ein schwein eschborner
der schweine ist bond allerdings hat mir
tobi geschrieben ein kleiner 1.8 fake
wenn du die mit dem wenn du dir mit dem
gift com hat ein mops ponholz habe ich
schon gemacht dann ist er ja
normalerweise schweine drin also das
sehen wir jetzt auch wenn man dann
allerdings zum beispiel mit einem cri
per rechtsklick darauf masse der
schweinitzer zum creepers borner das
heißt wir können jetzt beispielsweise
mal eben mit einem schicken richtig
drauf machen dann sehen wir darin schon
einen schicken und ansporn das teil
gleich schicken wir können mit einem
richtig drauf machen dann ist dein
creeper drin wir können auch theoretisch
mit einem gas dort rechts drauf machen
dann ist es ein gas bonner das kennen
wir schon aus käpt'n dinge aussieht und
ja ich würde sagen das ist ganz cool
wenn man quasi im creative oder wenn man
sich einem mordfall bauen will man den
seiner zwei welten nicht selber
irgendwie once upon a findet oder nur so
blöde zombies porno oder sondern
schwachsinn dann und die wollten
skeletts borner dann haben wir hier
beispielsweise gast dann könnt ihr das
einfach so machen jetzt in creative
gehen und euch quasi ein belieben einen
beliebigen spohle den ihr wollt machen
dann kann dich tobi meine sprache ist
mal wieder kommen wir zu fake nummer 3
und zwar wurde der mir zugesendet von
bacon sheep habe gerade etwas raus
gefunden und zwar an der 1.8 wenn man
einen blog zum beispiel erde mit einem
schwert an bord kann man das mit blocken
stoppen ohne dass das bereits abgebaut
sich ohne dass das bereits abgebaut ist
hat er wahrscheinlich vergessen sich
wieder zurück setzte lukas hat damit bei
insider geschrieben ihr sollt es mir
eigentlich nicht bei der installierten
auch guck mal da die thermik geschmissen
habe ihr sollt es möglich nicht bei
instagram schreiben eigentlich solche
sachen nicht aber ich fand's hat relativ
cool was ich übrigens auch mal sagen
würde wäre das wir geht die sonne unter
oder hat das einfach nur leicht darunter
gestaunt habe dass wir das ganze mal auf
die youtube kommentare verlagern von der
mail weil bei dem mail eingang habe ich
nie so die übersicht und bei youtube
kann man selber auch bewerten da könnt
ihr mir aufschreiben oder könnt ihr den
leuten direkt in die youtube com darin
schreiben könnt ihr antworten helga
funktioniert doch gar nicht und dann
kann ich sie wie viele daumen hoch seien
einzelne effekt hat also bitte mal in
dieser folge al effects unten in die
kommentare schreiben und unten in die
video kommentare damit ich das eventuell
damals sehen kann damit ich vergleichen
kann ist es besser mit e mail oder ist
es besser mit youtube kommentaren weil
ich denke die kommentare an sich durch
das daumen hoch werden und so relativ
gut verbessert dass man auch gute sachen
herausfiltern kann also schreibt mir
effekt auf jeden fall mal die you tube
kommentaren können das mal testen und
mich würd sagen ich zeige ich das ganze
mal ich bin im game mode 0 habe einen
dirt und einen stein schwer ich kann
auch ein holzschwert nehmen es relativ
egal
damit seit der steinzeit genommen weil
ich keinen bock hatte etwas anderes zu
nehmen
ich find die textur ganz cool also jetzt
ist jemand der trockenbau das ganze ab
jetzt kann ich rechts gedrückt halten
und ihr seht schon ich bin jetzt hier
auf dem blog drauf ich kann auch
weggehen blabla kann ich wieder drauf
gehen jetzt kann ich einfach so weiter
abbauen
das ist da
bei dem linksblock eventuell ganz
unnötig also ich meine erde ob ich halt
stopp oder nicht das geht ja eigentlich
relativ schnell dass abzubauen bei holz
kann ich auch einfach so drücken und
dann stoppt man beispielsweise mal
hinter mir gucken ob da ein krieg kann
ich wieder zurückgehen und dann kann ich
wieder so weiter abbauen und dann habe
ich hier quasi ein holzblock also das
ist auf jeden fall komani tief meint
oben dann kann dich becken schiebt das
auf jeden fall ne lustige sachen die ich
zum beispiel noch nicht wusste kommen
wir nun zu einem easter egg und zwar ist
es sehr sehr geil ihr habt es
wahrscheinlich schon auf dem feld
gesehen und fragt euch jetzt
wann kommt es endlich im video jetzt
kommt es und zwar können wir einfach auf
create new world klicken
wir nennen die einfach mal wille
jeopardy weil das ist jeder einzelne von
euch schreibt weil die kommentare heftig
wie jabba die hashtags villiger
vielleicht mache ich so ein shirt mit
hashtag villiger dann so villiger das
wäre echt cool vielleicht macht das aber
das ist also eine spontane idee
wir können hier ist mein creative gehen
und dann wissen wir es gibt default
superflat latsch bei uns und amplified
und customized customized das wo man
selber sagen kann ja kommen hier
ich möchte ja so hoch soll das wasser
stehen unsere blabla und dann gibt's
halt diese ganzen sachen wenn ihr dabei
leider dabei allerdings mal shift
gedrückt haltet also die tasten mit der
er sonst nix kommt irgendwann jetzt uns
relativ schnell hat bei mir auf den die
banknote kann einfach mal auf dann
klicken create your world und freunde
das ist jetzt der krasseste world den es
gibt das ist so krank ihr habt jeden
einzelnen blog jeder einzelne lava größe
also jeder einzelne größe die es von
blöcken gibt jeder einzelne anordnung
die schienen das feuer in allen
möglichen varianten in denen es
angezeigt wird jeden einzelnen blog den
es in minecraft gibt habt ihr in dieser
einzelnen welt hier drin und das ist
einfach perfekt geeignet wegen welche
texture pack vorstellungen oder
irgendwie sowas
also ich finde eigentlich nicht so
geschmeckt vorstellungen weil man
einfach sagen okay ich habe alle stunts
dornblüth haben wir hier
mehr ändert jetzt als cooler wenn man
das wirklich in der welt zeigt weil zum
beispiel so was so hug das sieht man
halt mega selten ich habe jetzt gerade
in sfax drin und ich finds halt aber
trotzdem cool um einfach mal anzuschauen
okay das ist mein text gepäck wenn ihr
selber eins mach ich komme kommt man mal
an wo ich hab die und die tür vergessen
zu machen und so das sieht man halt
oftmals nicht im normalen mode also das
ist ein easter egg was hinzugefügt wird
für tech speckbacher müsst ihr bei shift
gedrückt müsst ihr bei der weltauswahl
shift gedrückt halten und das auf jeden
fall ganz cool und zwar hat mit dass der
cube geschrieben dann kann dich cube und
dann will ich sagen machen wir weiter
mit dem fünften fact der fünfte wurde
mir zugesendet von jannik msc und zwar
schreibt er wenn du dieses zeichen was
man bei einem herz macht verwendet also
im chat da macht es automatisch einen
screenshot
dieser effekt ist mir beim herzchen
schreiben im chat aufgefallen also nicht
geklaut also danke an dich dann nicht
auch noch mal diese mit diesem geklaut
ist halt immer so eine blöde sache viel
effekt sie mir zugesendet werden gab
schon in anderen videos und so das ist
relativ uncool deswegen am besten effekt
schreiben jetzt rausgefunden hat oder
die euch freunde gesagt haben oder so
ach guck mal wie viel cooler aussetzung
zwecks finde ich das auch wenn es ist
überhaupt water ist auch ein
jedenfalls wenn ihr einen fisch denn das
manchmal tintenfische sony wollte von
ihm ein screenshot machen dann müsst ihr
sonst immer f2 drücken
und da steht auch so in den controlling
controls stehen sie irgendwo dieses
zeichen von dem herzen sondern da seht
ihr nur wo ist denn bei screenshots seht
ihr nur f2 da steht nichts von diesem
symbol als wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
dieses symbol mal rein schreibe so seht
ihr damit automatisch einen screenshot
gemacht ich kann jetzt hier zehn
millionen screenshots machen
immer wenn ich dieses symbol drücke von
diesem herzchen symbol und das ist auf
jeden fall eine ganz witzige sache da
muss man nicht immer also der einzige
grund warum das eigentlich als cooles
ist dass man nicht immer so blöd hoch
greifen musste f2 also ich komme viel
leichter wenn man die mit wer ist die
stadt an das kleine dreieck kinder dran
und es ist auch ganz witzig dass es
quasi ein steuerungselement ist was man
nicht bestimmen kann das kann man nicht
verändern
das heißt man kann das nicht irgendwie
in den einstellungen um bestimmen
sondern in den einstellung habe ich ja
schon gezeigt steht nur auf zwei drin
zum screenshot machen das ist auf jeden
fall eine sehr coole sache
dank an dich einig dass das haus
gefunden hast dann würde ich auch schon
sagen das war's mit der heutigen folge
war sogar normal lang obwohl ich
eigentlich relativ viele sachen los
geworden habe also nochmal
zusammengefasst freitags kommt nie ein
geräusch und dienstags kommt immer das
geräusch das heißt dann alle die keinen
groll stehen wollen bitte nur freitag
schauen und dienstags da nicht rum
hätten und ich habe einen typen gesehen
er geschrieben hat
scheiße du hast das geräusch gesagt erst
mal direkten display gegeben ist mein
neues hobby
da denkt man auch so was soll das genau
wegen solchen leuten mache ich quasi
diese umfrage ob ihr das ganze so haben
wollte und dann hätten sie trotzdem
rumpf als bei der umfrage von also ich
weiß nicht was daran halten soll
ich versuche ich da so viel wie möglich
aufeinander zuzugehen und bitte beruhigt
die leute mit dem geräusch oder wenn
irgendeiner nicht versteht dann schreibt
ihnen bitte in die kommentare
genauso wie die fixies mal in die
youtube kommentare schreiben weil ich
nicht weiß ob das jetzt mittlerweile
ganz gut funktioniert über die
kommentare ab schaut man da hinten wie
die sonne schon unter und dann würde ich
sagen freunde was es mit der heutigen
vorstellung jetzt euch gefallen hat weil
ich habe echt mühe gegeben auch mit dem
bearbeiten diesmal alles mögliche zu
machen dann gebt bitte daumen hoch
schaffen wir 5000 raumhoch das war
richtig cool schreibt alle willibald in
die kommentare ich bin so verletzt muss
jetzt ganz noch bearbeiten ich mag euch